india's supreme court will hold the
implementation of controversial new
agricultural laws
farmers have been blocking roads and
protesting around the capital since
november
they say the new laws will undercut
prices
elizabeth branham joins us now live from
the border crossing elizabeth tell us
more about this ruling
hello kim so the supreme court has said
that it is suspending
the implementation of these three farm
laws in light of the opposition
to them and that it's also going to form
a committee
to assess the situation both around the
laws
and the protests themselves the court
said that it's forming this committee
to resolve a situation that the
government has not been able to
and that anyone who is genuinely
interested in solving this problem where
we've seen
hundreds of thousands of indian farmers
blocking three major highways coming
into the indian capital for the last six
weeks
that anyone who's interested in solving
this problem should appear before the
committee
which will submit its report to the
court the supreme court has been
listening to both
farmers petitions against the laws and
the government's petitions against the
protests over the past two days
began hearing them on monday and it said
that it was extremely disappointed in
the government's
handling of the protests the fallout
from laws which it said it didn't think
the government had consulted farmers
enough before passing
it took note of the tens of farmers who
died protesting
out camping out in very cold conditions
and said that if any violence was to
break out who would be responsible for
it
and it is for all those reasons that
it's suspending the laws
until it's advised by its committee on
the way forward
okay liz uh what about the farmers have
we had any reaction
from them so far
[Music]
so the supreme court had indicated on
monday itself that it was likely to
suspend the implementation of these laws
and while farmers and farm unions
really welcomed the court censure very
strong
censure of the government they said that
suspending the laws isn't enough because
they don't trust that the laws will go
away if they're just halted if their
implementation is halted
and they're reiterating their demand
that these laws
be repealed they're also reluctant to
take part in any committees because
they've been negotiating with the
government for weeks now and there's
been
no breakthrough so far the government
meanwhile has said has told the court
that these laws were passed after two
decades of deliberations that they
weren't rushed through
it says farmers are happy with them
because it gives them more options
that they have been engaging with
farmers the court listened to all of
this
and also to the uh reluctance by farmers
to take part in any committee and it
said that it didn't want to hear that
that it's trying to solve the situation
and the alternative for farmers
is to protest indefinitely
all right elizabeth i'm there thank you
so much for that update